[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an american action crime
thriller film called safe
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
in nanjing china lives a little girl
named may she is a gifted mathematician
who can solve complicated mathematical
problems in her head she also has a
great memory and never forgets any
series of numbers she comes across
one day mae is walking home with her
friends when a group of men abducts her
she is taken to a chinese mafia leader
named han the digital data of han's
criminal enterprise is traceable hence
he wants to use mai as his personal
mental calculator who can memorize the
data for him initially the little girl
refuses to cooperate but when he
threatens to kill her mother she agrees
to do as told under the care of their
trusted gang member chang mai is brought
to new york where she is hidden as his
daughter somewhere else in new jersey
former cop and cage fighter luke is in
an intense match with his opponent he
has set the match up and is supposed to
lose but he accidentally throws a good
punch at his opponent and knocks him out
straight into a coma the win angers the
head of the russian mafia emil who lost
millions of dollars on luke luke
realizes that an angry gangster would
mean that his family is in trouble he
rushes home but is too late because the
russians rushed faster the gangster's
son vasily has already killed his
pregnant wife luke is devastated by the
death and although he can fight he
doesn't retaliate the thugs then promise
to kill anyone with whom he speaks to or
makes contact with nowhere and no one to
go to luke returns to his hometown new
york he starts living as a homeless
person wandering around in the streets
of manhattan one year later mai is still
working with the gang chang takes her on
a weekly round of the streets in
chinatown she memorizes the percentage
of net profit or loss every store faces
the store owners are supposed to pay the
gang a certain amount of money according
to their profit hence mai has proven to
be a useful asset to them throughout her
time working with the gang she has
learned a lot about how business works
in the gangster world somewhere else
luke lives in a highly unorganized
homeless shelter one night he meets a
man with no shoes and severely infected
feet out of sympathy he gives the man
his new shoes but the next day he wakes
up to discover that someone slit the
poor guy's throat and stole the shoes
overnight suffice to say that luke's
living conditions are poor meanwhile a
lady working closely with chang
approaches mai in the middle of the
night and informs her of her mother's
death back in china it turns out that
she was severely sick and in hospital
the following day the leader of the gang
han comes to new york for the first time
since he sent mai he has come with a
piece of paper with a series of numbers
on it maya's asked to memorize the
number which she does in less than 10
seconds the numbers seem to be of great
importance because han burns the piece
of paper to ashes so only mai would know
what they are after that chang takes her
to the next location mai is told that
she will have to memorize the second
series of numbers when she reaches the
destination everything goes according to
plan until they are attacked by the
russian mafia led by emil the gangster
who killed luke's wife they are also
after mai because of the numbers she has
memorized a shootout ensues where the
chinese gangsters lose to the russians
who abduct mai somewhere else luke is
having a bad day because a passerby
stole his breakfast money while trying
to buy something he bumps into his
former colleague from the police force
the man instantly recognizes luke and
takes him to an abandoned building with
his fellow cops a long time ago luke
debunked their corrupt ways of helping
the local gangsters the cops are still
furious at him for getting them in
trouble back then they beat him up and
insult him but he doesn't retaliate in
the end a cop hands luke a gun urging
him to end his own life but luke refuses
and walks away at the same time mai is
taken to the russian gang leader emil
who asks her about the numbers she soon
finds out that the lady who told her
about her mother was helping a meal the
entire time the lady also asks mai to
tell them the code but in turn mai
claims that the woman is going to die
because she doesn't know how business
works right afterwards the men shoot her
dead since she is of no use to them
anymore mai knows she will suffer the
same fate if she tells them the number
hence she keeps quiet
just then a corrupt cop and one of
luke's former colleagues captain wolf
comes to the russian hideout to catch
the criminals however he is not doing it
for the law but on the orders of the
chinese leader han emil calls the
captain and offers him double the money
than the chinese gangsters to get away
from his hideout the corrupt captain
accepts the deal and retreats by this
time mai has run away from the hideout
without anyone seeing her both the
russians and chinese gangsters start
looking for her in hopes of finding her
before the other group does mai
eventually reaches the subway station
where luke is about to end his life he
is seconds away from jumping on the
tracks when he locks eyes with the
scared little girl and stops himself he
also notices the gangsters who killed
his wife looking for the little girl to
run away from them she gets on the
subway but the gang gets a glimpse of
her and follows luke realizes something
is wrong and makes it his mission to
save the girl he latches onto the subway
and kills all the russians on his way
one of them recognizes luke as the guy
they beat up a year ago he is surprised
as to how someone so submissive can
defeat all their people in minutes in
the end he is also killed and luke
finally meets mai but as soon as the
subway stops she runs away with the
crowd mistaking luke for one of the bad
guys on his way to look for her luke
overhears a red alert code being relayed
to all the cops he registers that the
girl is also wanted by the corrupt
policeman who will definitely hand her
to the mafia a few minutes in two cops
who beat up luke earlier find the girl
and try to take her away luke arrives at
the right time and knocks them out in an
instant proving that he was staying
quiet only because he wanted to mai
still doesn't trust him but gets into a
car with him when the russian mafia
arrives a high-speed car chase ensues in
the streets of manhattan at last luke
kills all the russians steals their
wallets and takes mai to a fancy hotel
somewhere else the captain finds out
that maya was taken by force not by the
mafia but by luke he is in shock because
luke hasn't been involved in anything
crime related since he left the police
force meanwhile after checking into the
hotel mai starts to trust luke and tells
him about the numbers she memorized upon
checking the format of the numbers he
figures out that it is the combination
of a safe mai says she was supposed to
memorize a second sequence before the
russians attacked which means there are
two safes with something valuable in
them probably being traded by the
chinese mafia
just then chang finds out mai's location
using a tracking device in her phone he
and his henchmen arrive at the hotel and
start a shootout chaos ensues as people
start to run for their lives eventually
luke gets into a fist fight with the
gangsters which causes him and mai to
separate chang gets his hands on her
while luke escapes before he is killed
he knows that he cannot leave mai alone
and is ready to do anything to get her
back safe so he calls the russian leader
emile's son vasily from a phone he stole
earlier vasily is also the guy who
killed luke's wife a year ago luke
pretends to be their gang member and
claims that he has the number that
everyone is looking for vasily believes
him and calls him to a casino to deliver
the said number
somewhere else the city's mayor calls
the corrupt police captain to his office
to discuss all the shootings it turns
out that he and his boyfriend alex are
also just as corrupt as the others the
mayor reveals that luke wasn't a normal
cop in fact he was a cia agent loaned to
the police force after 9 11. while he
was in the police force he and his
former partner alex assassinated several
crime bosses in an effort to impose
order however luke had to quit after
exposing the corrupt ways of the captain
and his squad alex stayed and seduced
the mayor to get where he is now the
captain finally realizes that the guy he
thought was a loser is actually the most
dangerous enemy he has ever had
currently luke's former partner alex is
the mayor's boyfriend who has gone
corrupt like him when the mayor is
informed about mai and luke being
together he gets nervous it is almost as
if he knows something about the safe and
the combination on it in the meantime
mai is brought back to the leader han
who inquires if she told the combination
to anyone she lies and insists that she
pretended to not understand english
chang calls alex and tells him that they
have the girl so they can continue the
meeting it is then revealed that the
people the chinese mafia was trying to
do business with are the mayor and his
boyfriend alex they are trading the
unknown contents of their respective
safes kind of like selling unopened
boxes of pokemon cards next luke arrives
at the casino where he finds the russian
gangsters he ambushes all of vasily's
henchmen and takes them hostage planning
to use them to threaten the russian
leader emile he calls emil and asks him
about the contents of the safe in
exchange for his son's life emile
discloses that the safe with the chinese
gangsters has 30 million dollars in it
while the safe with the mayor has
something that is worth the
aforementioned money the parties were
about to trade using the little girl but
the russians stepped in and destroyed
the plan however now that the chinese
have my the plan is back on track chang
goes to meet alex and exchange the codes
now the only way for luke to save the
girl is by getting the 30 million
dollars from the chinese mafia before
the trade takes place but he cannot do
it on his own because the safe is hidden
deep in chinatown and protected by the
most dangerous of the chinese gangsters
so he asks for help from his former cop
colleagues they agree to help but only
because of the money the group then
walks into the hideout and starts a
shootout on the way several gangsters
and cops die but not jason statham
because he still has to fist fight some
more people when they finally reach the
locker luke betrays the cops and shoots
them dead except the captain who he
holds hostage alongside vasily he also
takes the money from the safe and makes
his way to the mayor's office on his way
he calls alex and asks him what is in
the second safe because luke has the
money alex is bound to do everything he
asks he reveals the second safe belongs
to the mayor containing a disc with data
on every crime syndicate in new york the
mayor wanted to sell it to the chinese
take the 30 million and let the gangs
deal with what they had to alex was
about to hold the deal with chang but
since the money has already been stolen
he tries to return to meet luke instead
but luke orders him to bring mai along
because she is an important asset alex
follows the orders kills chang and his
henchmen and drives to meet luke along
with the girl in the following scene
luke breaks into the mayor's office and
asks him for the contents of the second
safe although the mayor is reluctant he
has no choice but to hand luka disc with
the data luke knocks him out and returns
to meet alex like promised with both the
money and the information he is the most
powerful one in the game but alex has
something more special my when the two
finally meet to exchange mai for the
money luke refuses to cooperate instead
suggesting that they settle it with a
fight alex gets ready but is shot in the
leg by my taking the opportunity luke
kills him with ease he and mai are
finally free with the money and the desk
that they can use for protection for my
safety luke lets the captain free with
fifty thousand dollars as compensation
for his troubles he also lets vasily go
so the russians wouldn't come after them
then there is the chinese mafia leader
han who got his money and mai stolen
from him luke sends him all of the
remaining money so he wouldn't try to
look for mai anymore at last he hides
several copies of the disc throughout
the city in case someone tries to harm
them they can use the drive as a way to
blackmail some powerful people in the
last scene mai and luke drive to seattle
to start a new life
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching